The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
HONG LIU: So last time we
talked about what corresponding
to external fundamental
quark in [INAUDIBLE] series.
So you can see there [? m ?]
plus 1 is [? rebrain. ?] Then
you separate one of them.
You separate one of them.
And then you can see there
one string connect between,
then you can see that
the open string connect
between this [? m ?] and this 1.
And such object from
the point of view,
because this end
have a unique index.
And this end have indices.
So this will transform
on the fundamental
[? representation ?]
of this SU(N).
Because when you're reshuffling
the indices of this [? n, ?]
and this will
transform as a vector,
because there's only one
end [INAUDIBLE] on it.
So this is the field
series picture.
Then in the gravity
picture, when
you go to AdS, so when
you take a [INAUDIBLE]
in the gravity side, then
this M-Brain just disappeared.
And then you have
a boundary, say
i equal to infinity,
or z equal to 0.
And then you find in
a suitable [INAUDIBLE]
that the single brain
still remains there.
And then this string
become a string
just an ending on this
brain, but extend all the way
to i equal to 0.
Because all the other
end, this [? rebrain ?]
not disappeared, but
replaced by the geometry.
So now what you find
in the gravity side,
this just become
a single D-Brain,
single [? D ?] [? rebrain ?] now
in the AdS 5 Now in the AdS 5.
And there's one point on the S5.
So depending on the direction.
So this will be extended
in some direction,
in the transverse direction,
to this [? rebrain. ?]
And so that direction
determines the point on the S5.
So we're relying on the
single point on the S5.
And all this special
dimension is parallel
to the boundary direction.
So this, is the geometry clear?
Good.
And now if we want, you can
see the external quark which
have infinite
mass, then you want
to put this brain
to the boundary,
because the mass of this quark
is controlled by the length.
So you want this
length go to infinite.
Then you put it to the boundary.
And, yeah.
Essentially.
So this picture tells
you that the external
quark in [INAUDIBLE] theory.
Then you just mapped to a
string ending on the boundary.
A string ending on the boundary.
Do you have any questions
regarding this picture?
And the mass of the string,
as we discussed before,
either from this picture
the mass of the string
would be the length divided
by 2 pi alpha prime.
And that this mass getting
[INAUDIBLE] to this picture.
And then you can check it
as a self-consistency check
that the straight string
extend all the way say
from some radius,
from some location r,
to the i equal to 0, and
precisely have this mass.
So now let me make a note.
So as we said before, if
you say an ordinary [? K ?]
[? series ?], if you
take an external quark,
say moving in the fundamental
[? representation. ?] And when
you parallel transport that
quark say along some loop,
then you get the Wilson loop.
Then you get the Wilson loop.
But in this case, the
parallel transport
of this m of such
an external quark
actually gives
something which is
slightly different from
the standard Wilson loop.
So at the standard Wilson
loop is the following.
It's you take the trace,
[? your ?] path order,
and the exponential--
say i, A mu,
say supposed S parameterize
the length along the path.
And then you have A mu.
And then you have dx mu ds.
So this is the
standard Wilson loop.
But in this case, actually
you have something
more in the exponential
for the following reason.
So in the [INAUDIBLE]
series, you'll
not only have a gate field.
You'll also have a scalar field.
As we [? stated ?]
before, the scalar field
parameterizes the
external fluctuation
in the transverse
direction of the D-Brains.
So now if you imagine you have a
string ending on such D-Brains,
just by mechanical thinking,
really mechanical thinking,
if you have something
ending on the D-Brain,
and if this thing
have a mass, and it
got to pull this D-Brain
in the direction.
Because this thing have a
[? finite ?] [? tension. ?] So
you want to pull the D-Brain.
So that means that
the string actually
will deform as a shape
of the D-Brain around
at the ending point.
So what that means is
that the string should
couple to the scalar
field on the D-Brain.
Such open string should
couple to the scalar
field on the D-Brain.
The scalar field paramertize
the transfer direction
and the transfer motion.
And the string should
pull the D-Brain.
So this open string got to
couple to the scalar fields.
So this is a rough
[? infusion. ?]
But you can work
this out explicitly.
You just take this series.
So this is SU(N)
[INAUDIBLE] series, N + 1,
your [INAUDIBLE] series.
And then you break
to SU (N) times u(1).
So this open string
goes bounding
to the off diagonal
degree of freedom,
of going into this breaking
between the N and the 1,
and corresponding to explicit
field in this series.
And you can just work out the
[? dynamically ?] of the field.
You can usually check
that actually this
coupled to the scalar field.
So I will not go
into detail there.
But you can work
out more explicitly.
So the bottom line
is that such objects,
we are not only coupled
to the gate field,
but also coupled to
the scalar fields.
And if you work
it out explicit;y,
it will couple to the scalar
field in the following way.
So a limit you not [? define. ?]
So you have six scalar fields.
Let me denote them as a vector.
Yeah.
So now let me explain
this notation.
So this n essentially the
direction of the string.
So n is a unit
vector on S 5, which
is a location of
that D-Brain, which
is enabled the location
of this D-Brain
is 5, because it's in
some transverse direction.
And the 5 is just the
six scalar fields,
which I writed the vector, six
fields of [INAUDIBLE] series.
And then the dot x squared is
just the modulus of this guy.
You have any questions on this?
So now, because this is the
Wilson loop corresponding
to such an external quark.
And actually, when you
consider the string dynamics
on the gravity
side, that we will
relate to the expectation
value, for example,
of this Wilson loop.
Not the standard one.
So now let's consider such
a quark traverses some path
C, some loop C on the boundary.
So I will make two statements.
And from these two
statements, then we
will be able to
guess what the Wilson
loop will be corresponding
to on the gravity sides.
So the first statement
is that this quark,
lies under the endpoint
of a string in AdS.
So that means the C-- so the
loop formed by this quark
trajectory, there must be the
boundary of the corresponding
string [? worksheet. ?] So let
me call this [? worksheet ?]
sigma.
So in other words, the
C must be corresponding
to the boundary of the sigma.
So the second statement is
that the expectation value
of the Wilson loop-- so this can
see considered as the partition
function of this quark system.
So you can think about the
expectation value of the Wilson
loop as the following.
So you take the quark, and
write down the path integral
for this quark.
Write down the path of
the quark along this loop,
and then just integrate all
of the dynamics of the quark.
And then what you remaining
would be just the Wilson loop.
So you can just imagine this
Wilson loop corresponding
to the partition function
of this quark system.
So now from our experience
with the duality, now
we can just make a guess.
We can just make a
guess, because we always
identify one partition function
with the other partition
function.
They should be the same object.
So now we should be able to
identify the expectation value
of the Wilson loop with the
string [? Cartesian ?] function
of this particular string,
which ending at the boundary,
the string partition
function, and the host whose
[? worksheet ?] ending
at the boundary as at C.
So this is just, you can
just make a natural guess.
You have any questions
regarding this guess?
Good.
So now let me may say a
few words about this guy.
So suppose an [INAUDIBLE] just
parameterize say M sigma alpha
to parameterize the
[? worksheet. ?] Say sigma
alpha is the
worksheet coordinates,
and [? XM ?] are the
coordinate on the AdS.
And then this parameterized
a string moving AdS.
And then the string
partition function,
you can just write it as DX.
You integrate of all possible
X. And then the string action
with the boundary condition that
the worksheet of the boundary
should ending on C.
So this essentially
is the right-hand side.
So according to
your convenience,
you can either choose
the string action
say to be a lambigoto or
[? Poliakoff ?] as you want.
A Poliakoff.
For example, let me just write
down the remind you what is
the [? lambigoto. ?] For the
[? lambigoto, ?] you just 2 pi
alpha prime delta h.
And the h is the
induced the matrix on
the [? worksheet. ?]
H is induced matrix on
the [? worksheet. ?] Yeah.
So in principle we have
a precise mathematical
formulation we can work with.
Then you can check
whether this proposal
makes sense, et cetera.
Of course, again, this object
is very hard to calculate.
Yeah, I should say you may also
include the fermions, depending
on superstring [INAUDIBLE]
you may have other things.
But this is the
most basic object,
So again, this
object in principle
very difficult to calculate,
but then become simple
if we can see the g string
goes to the 0 limit,
and the alpha prime
goes to the 0 limit.
So in the g string
goes to 0 limit,
you remember, then we connect
a different topologies.
You can just stick to
the lowest topology.
So in other words, you can,
when g string goes to 0,
you can neglect splitting
or joining on the string.
So you can just can see that
the worksheet with the simplest
topology.
And in alpha prime
goes to 0 limit.
So alpha prime appears
as a prefactor.
1 over alpha prime
appears as a prefactor
in this [? worksheet ?] series.
Whether you do the
[? Poliakoff ?] or you do
the [? lambogotto, ?]
it's the same thing.
So alpha prime essentially
plays to the coupling
constant on the [? worksheet. ?]
So the alpha prime
goes to 0 limit.
So alpha prime is
essentially the h bar
on the [? worksheet, ?]
is the [? factive ?] h bar
on the [? worksheets. ?] So
when alpha prime goes to 0,
you can evaluate, then
the path integral.
Just LIKE in the
gravity formulation,
we can evaluate
the path integral
when the g Newton goes to 0.
So here we can evaluate path
integral using the sadale point
approximation.
The sadale point.
So this is [INAUDIBLE].
It implies, in the
sadale point especially,
essentially you just evaluate
the classical action.
Just find the
classical solution,
classical string solution.
And then evaluate the action
on that classical solution.
And so this is
corresponding to [INAUDIBLE]
fluctuation of the
[? worksheets. ?]
So as I said, this
alpha prime appears
in a [? worksheet ?]
action just as the place
which the h bar appears.
And so when you take
alpha prime goes
to 0 limit, then
corresponding to your,
you neglect the fluctuation
of the [? worksheet. ?]
Then you can just can see that
the classical string dynamics.
Then in this limit, then
we can do this easily.
So that means in the g
string goes to the 0 limit,
and the alpha prime
goes to 0 limit, which
again translate on
the field series side
to include infinity.
And the lambda goes
to infinite limit.
Then we can write the
expectation value of the Wilson
loop just as the classical
action-- the action
for the string evaluated
as a classical solution.
So S cl is the action evaluated
at a classical solution.
So essentially you just have a
[? regions ?] [? worksheet. ?]
Any questions on this?
So now we can talk
about some examples.
So the simplest example
is that it's just
considered a static quark.
A static quark does not move.
So if this is a
time direction, then
the [INAUDIBLE]
line of the quark
is just a straight line
moving in the time direction.
And say from minus
infinity, plus infinity.
And then you can imagine
close to the loop at infinity.
Anyway, this is just
a straight line.
So this is a simple situation.
And so a level is convenient
to give a length to this line,
the time direction.
So they record the total
length as T-- capital T.
And then without
calculating, essentially
by definition the expectation
value of the Wilson loop
should be just minus i MT.
So this is just the phase factor
associated with [INAUDIBLE].
This [? thing ?] under
the quark does not move.
And the M is the total
energy of the quark,
the mass of the quark.
And then you just have
the standard [INAUDIBLE]
[? i ET. ?]
So now let's try to calculate
on the gravity side.
Now let's try to calculate what
is the corresponding object
to this on the gravity side.
So now let me just remind
you the AdS [? metric. ?]
So we can use the
two difference way,
say whether using
this R coordinate,
or using this Z coordinate.
And they're related by
a very simple coordinate
transformation.
Just 1 over.
Remind you of that.
So on the gravity side, so
let's now draw our boundary.
So this is r equal to
infinity, or z equal to 0.
So the r increase in this
direction, and the z increase
in that direction.
So such objects on
the gravity side,
just from the description
we said earlier,
was just corresponding
to a string.
Does not move at all.
Extends from the boundary
all the way to the interior.
And because this is just a
single quark and does not move.
This is just our
previous picture.
So we can parameterize it.
So as we discussed
before, this action
is reparameterization
environment.
So that means we can choose
the sigma and the tau
at this 2 sigma coordinate.
So sigma alpha.
And we'll call the
tau on the sigma.
So I can choose the
tau on the sigma
as we want according
to the convenience.
So for this one, let
me choose tau equal
just t at the real space time t.
So that's t.
And then take the sigma along
the radial direction, this r.
So this straight string
just corresponding
to the solution, which x
i t r equal to constant.
So this is a string
which does not move.
So the other directions,
it just a constant.
If you put it at some
point, it stays there.
So this is the obvious
solution of that configuration.
So you can check.
This is indeed a solution to
the [? lambogoto ?] action.
I will not check
there, because this is
the essentially started with.
So you can immediately tell
this must be a solution.
So low let's try to find the
classical action corresponding
to this solution.
So for this purpose, we
have to work the [INAUDIBLE]
[? metric. ?] So the easiest
way to work out this the reduced
[? metric ?] as follows.
So the [? worksheet ?]
[? metric ?] would be h alpha
beta.
So it is sigma
alpha to sigma beta.
And h alpha beta is
given by this guy.
And the easiest way to work
out is that you just write down
the AdS [? metric. ?] And now
you think that [? ht ?] and X
and r as a function
of the sigma tau.
And you just substitute
the functions in.
So t just equal to tau.
So this just becomes
t tau squared.
But X is independent of t and r.
So when I write the space
time coordinates, I use x.
But when I write
it as a coordinate
as a function of
the [? worksheet ?],
then I use the capital.
So this is just to emphasize,
this is a function.
Anyway, and here I replace by
that X which is independent
of [? ht ?].
So there's nothing here.
And now the R square
become sigma squared.
So it become sigma squared,
because i just equal to sigma.
And then this is my
[? worksheet ?] [? metric. ?]
Sigma square, r square minus d
tau square plus r square sigma
square [? d sigma ?] squared.
So this is my induced
[? worksheet ?] [? metric ?]
for this special worksheet.
And if you imagine,
there's a time direction,
which is this string
just translate
in the time direction.
Does not move.
So now we can easily work
out what is the determinant.
This is diagonal [? metric. ?]
You see these two cancel.
So the determinant
just equal to one.
So now we can write down
the [? worksheet ?] action.
Let me erase here.
So the [? worksheet ?] action S
N [? g ?] will be just minus 1
over 2 pi alpha prime.
Now the theta h is
just equal to 1.
Then I just have
integration of dt.
Then I have integration of
dr, because tau equal to t
and sigma equal to r.
And r should be
from 0 to infinity.
So this integration of dt just
give us a capital T factor.
And then this is divergent.
So normally when we see
something divergent,
as we always do, we just
say this is not at infinity.
Let's put a small cutoff
here at i equal to lambda.
So if I do that, and then
this here become lambda.
So now if you read
from here, this
should be identified with wc.
I times of that object
And that should be
equal to minus iMT.
So we conclude that
the mass must be
lambda over 2 pi alpha prime.
But this is actually what I
just advertised earlier, said
you can check it explicitly,
that the mass of the object
is precisely just the radial
location divided by r, divided
by 2 pi alpha prime.
And I just confirmed
that expectation.
I just confirmed
So this is infinite
by design, because I
want to have an infinite
mass quark so that I
don't have a fluctuation.
And so in principle
I can take lambda.
It's not just I want.
But actually I can
show the lambda.
So it actually make sense.
So physically you
should think there's
some kind of
[? disequilibrium ?]
here which I can
show the location.
And in the end, I take
lambda go to infinity,
because I want the
mass go to infinity.
So it's also instructive to
rewrite this in terms of the z.
So in terms of the d, and
the z is related to capital R
by this way, So in
this corresponding
to a small thing in z.
So z will be R squared.
So this corresponding to
a cut off z at epsilon.
At epsilon.
So we can write this
M in terms of z.
Then equal to become
2 pi alpha prime R
squared divided by epsilon.
So now let me do one more step.
So as we said before, that
in terms of z-coordinate,
so you'll also have
checked yourself
by doing this holographic
bound exciter.
So this epsilon can be
conceived as a short distance
cutoff because of the
boundary, [INAUDIBLE]
cut off at boundary.
So this can also be conceived
as the mass of the quark.
And due to that, you put
some short distance cutoff.
Say epsilon distance
away from the quark.
And so now let's remember the
dictionary R square divided
by alpha prime is related to
on the gravity side to what?
Do you remember?
Yeah.
A limit, right?
The big box here.
So R to the power of 4
divided by alpha prime
squared equal to what?
Equal to lambda, which
is the g [INAUDIBLE]
square N [INAUDIBLE]
g square N. And then
the five-dimensional
Newton constant divided
by R cubed, that is related
to the N. So this is-- I
think it's pi divided
by 2 N squared.
You don't need to remember
the precise prefactors.
But you should remember that R
squared divided by alpha prime
is related to lambda.
So lambda is the root coupling.
So now we can rewrite this as
the square root lambda divided
by 2 pi, then 1 over epsilon.
So there's something
interesting here.
He said there's a
square root lambda.
It's the square root
lambda appearing here.
And this is a square
root, g squared times N.
So if you remember
in the [? QED ?],
so if you try to calculate
what the [? self ?] energy
of the electron in
the most naive way.
So electron naively have an
infinite potential energy,
because if you go
closer to the electron,
and then the energy
will blow up.
But if you put a small
cutoff around the electron,
then what would be energy.
You would you get?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
HONG LIU: Yep.
Say if you put two electrons.
Two electrons.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
HONG LIU: Yeah.
You use a lot of electrons.
You probe it.
Then you would get e square.
You would get e square.
But here, interesting
thing is that it's
proportional to the square
root of the e square.
This is proportional to the
square root of e square.
So this square root lambda is
essentially the strong coupling
prediction.
We will say more about this.
So we have finished.
This simple example
seems to make sense.
So this just corresponding
to a mass of the quark.
So now let's do something
a little bit more
[? nontrivial ?].
So let's consider the static
potential between a quark
and the anti-quark.
So from the field
series side, we
can see that such
a configuration.
So suppose this is
some x 1 direction.
So this is a time direction.
So we can see
there's such a loop.
So this is L in
the x 1 direction.
Say this is L divided by 2.
And this is minus
L divided by 2.
And in the T direction,
again the length
is capital T. The
length is capital T.
And we always take the T
to be much, much greater
than L. Essentially you can
imagine this T as infinite.
So as we mentioned last time, if
you can see the loop like this,
when the T become much,
much greater than L,
you can forget about the
beginning part and the end
part.
Essentially, you have
two parallel line.
And the parallel lines in the
opposite direction in time,
then you can see that
this is this corresponding
to a quark, this corresponding
to the anti-quark moving
parallel in time.
And then again, the
expectation of the Wilson loop
should give you-- so
this is a static system.
This is a system with
translation variance in time.
If I take T go to infinite, you
can imagine as a translation
variance in time.
And then due to this
translation variance in time,
you can write it to [INAUDIBLE].
It must have the falling
form, just on general ground.
And e totally is just the
total energy of the system.
Just in quantum mechanics.
In quantum mechanics, any
translation variance system,
the whole thing just minus iE T.
And the total
should corresponding
to the mass over the
two external quark,
then plus the potential energy
between them [INAUDIBLE]
energy between them.
So if you calculate this
Wilson loop in say [? QCD. ?]
So that will give you the
force between the quark
and the anti-quark, et cetera.
But in general, if you have
a strongly coupled [? gate ?]
series, we don't know how
to do such a calculation.
It's very hard to do.
But in this case, equipped with
this, equipped by this, then
the gravity will help us
to do this calculation.
So the gravity can help us
find V(L) and strong coupling.
So now we want to calculate
the string [? worksheets ?]
corresponding to
such configuration.
Do you have any questions
regarding our set-up?
Good.
So now let's write.
You can see that the
gravity side again, this
is the boundary of AdS.
And now let's imagine
this is our x 1 direction.
Then we have a quark
here at L divided by 2.
And then have anti-quark
here at minus L divided by 2.
So you can see that these two
lines, it's one from quark,
one from anti-quark.
And now this is
translates in time.
So this the r equal to
infinite, or z equal to 0.
So if we just have two
isolated quark, if each of them
are isolated, then the
string [? worksheet ?],
we are just as we said before,
just two straight line.
Just two straight line.
And that's corresponding
to an isolated quark.
But now these two
quark can interact.
Can interact.
So the magic expectation is
that this string [? worksheet ?]
will get deformed, and the
[INAUDIBLE] expectations
that they will just
connect to each other.
So you expect the
string [? worksheet ?]
will be like this.
So if the string
[? worksheet ?] is like this,
that means there's no
interaction between these two
quarks.
And now if the two string,
yeah, so this is the quark.
And then this is the anti-quark.
So they should have
opposite orientation.
And then the string
[? worksheet ?],
we have orientation like this.
So it will go off like this.
So now you expect that
the [? worksheet ?]
will be like this.
And again, it's transition
variant in time.
Any questions on this?
Is this clear to you?
So geometrically,
this is only way
which these two quark can have
interactions is by joining
their [? worksheet ?] together.
AUDIENCE: So generally, we
would be doing the path integral
over all the closed strings that
have those boundary emissions.
Sorry.
Open string.
HONG LIU: Yeah.
That's right.
Yeah.
Good.
So now with this
realization, then the rest
become mechanical.
Not quite mechanical.
Yeah.
So we can choose, as
before, tau equal to T.
So T equals infinity.
So we can consider the system
translation variant in time.
So let's choose again tau
equal to T. So we can also
chose the sigma
still equal to R.
But now let me do it
slightly differently.
So let me do it
sigma equal to x 1.
So you can do both.
But just to give you
a variety, [INAUDIBLE]
sigma equals to x 1, because
x 1 [? direction also ?]
become nontrivial.
And let me choose
sigma equal to x 1.
And then this
[? worksheet ?] then
is parameterized
just by z, which
is only a function of sigma.
So sigma runs from
minus half L to L.
And then this string would be
parameterized by some function
z as a function of sigma.
And because of the
translation variance,
you cannot have dependence on t.
Cannot have dependence on t.
And also, all the other
directions are not equal to 1.
They should be just
constant, because they're not
moving in the other directions.
So they should be
just constants.
So the only non-trivial thing
would be in the x 1 direction.
You can also choose
the sigma to be z,
and the x 1 would
be a function of z,
then the x 1 would be
a function of sigma.
You can do it either way.
Doesn't matter.
So the boundary condition
would be z re-evaluated
at plus minus 1/2 L.
Then this of course
should be at the boundary.
So it should be equal to 0.
So this is the
boundary condition
that this starting
from the boundary.
So now let's try to write down
the [? worksheet ?] action.
Let's try to write down
the [? worksheet ?]
metric under the
[? worksheet ?] action.
So the [? worksheet ?]
metric is again as
what we were doing before.
You can just write down
i equal to z square minus
dt square plus dx
square plus tz square.
So now t equal to tau.
So dt squared just
become d tau square.
And the [? dx 1 ?] square just
become [? d ?] sigma square.
under the others.
We don't need to care.
So this just become
d sigma square.
And the z is a
function of sigma.
So this just become z prime
sigma square d sigma square.
And then you just find
this is equal to R square
z square d tau square plus
1 plus z prime squared
d sigma square.
So this is the induced metric
on the [? worksheet ?].
And then you can now write down
the [? lambagoto ?] action.
So it just 1 over 2 pi
alpha prime d 2 sigma.
And then you take
the determinant
of this metric,
which is easy to do.
You get R square factor out.
And then you get
1 over d square.
And it just square root
of 1 plus z prime squared.
So this is the square
root determinant.
So we can do a little bit of
[? massage. ?] So this d 2
sigma is dt d sigma.
And the sigma is from minus L to
1/2 L, because this is a sigma,
is x 1 from minus L to 1/2 L.
So [INAUDIBLE] depend on t.
So we can just replace it
by a factor of capital T.
And obviously this system
have symmetry between the x
and the minus x.
And then I can just choose the
integration from half of it.
So I do it from 0
to L divided by 2.
And then I eliminated 2
on the [? downstairs. ?]
So this is my action.
Then what I need to do is
I need to [? extremize ?].
This is action
respect to z sigma.
Then you solve
for z sigma, which
satisfy the boundary condition.
And then solve for z sigma.
And then find S
classical action.
So now this reduce to
a freshmen problem--
literally, little
cute freshman problem.
So which is actually quite fun
to do with a little bit twist.
With a little bit twist.
So do you want to
do it immediately,
or do want to have a break?
So now let's try to do this.
Try to do this.
So first, just by
consistency we expect
this thing must be divergent,
because this contains 2M.
But 2M in our set-up,
if you start something
from the boundary,
and the M is infinite,
then we would expect this
thing to be divergent.
We would expect something
to be divergent.
And indeed, you see
the dangerous thing
is that when the sigma
approach [INAUDIBLE] over 2,
then you have a 1
over d square here,
and at this z of 1
over 2, this is 0.
So there is some potential
divergences here.
But of course you
also have to look
at the behavior of this term.
By this you see there is some
potential divergence here.
And this is expected,
because we know
that this must contain the 2M.
And if this whole
story is consistent,
there must be a divergent.
So let us just write
with that in mind.
So let me just subtract
the 2 MT from here.
So this [? UNG ?].
So this is supposed
to be minus i E
total T. So from
this expectation,
we would write V(L).
So now again I replace the R
square divided by alpha prime
by square root lambda.
So we have square
root lambda pi.
Then L divided by 2 d
sigma 1 over z square 1
plus z prime square.
And the minus now
1 over epsilon.
Because the [? twice ?]
the M is just
the square root of pi divided by
the square root lambda divided
by pi times 1 over epsilon.
So I take out this factor.
And so we expect the
V(L) [INAUDIBLE].
So if this guess we have
said earlier is correct,
that the partition
function. of the Wilson loop
should be related
to the partition
function of the string,
and then reduced
to a classical action, et
cetera-- if that idea is right,
we should find by
self consistency
that this thing
should be finite.
This thing should be
finite, and should also
be [? inactive, ?] because
the quark and the anti-quark
have an attractive force.
So we should find this thing
to be finite and negative.
You see, this guy is
actually positive.
And no matter what is z, this
guy is actually positive.
So that means that this guy must
be smaller than 1 over epsilon.
And so you get something active.
So this guy must be some 1
over epsilon lambda something.
So now let me call this
to be my Lagrangian.
So now we had to do a small
variation of the problem.
Yeah.
Maybe not confused by that
L. Let me put this script
L. So this is my Lagrangian.
And then this is a
one-dimensional Lagrangian
problem.
And this Lagrangian does
not depend on sigma.
So we treat the sigma as time.
So this is like a
one-dimensional problem
with the sigma as time.
So if the Lagrangian
does not depend on time,
what's going to happen?
AUDIENCE: Energy conservation.
HONG LIU: Exact.
The energy's conserved.
So we can write down the energy
corresponding to this guy.
And the energy is z
prime pi z minus L.
So this must be constant.
And the pi z, just the economic
momentum conjugates to the z.
So all this is very elementary.
You can immediately
write down this equation,
[? h of 1 over ?] d square.
So you find the
pi you plug here.
Then you find this equation.
This equation just become that.
So now let's try to
parameterize this constant.
So the way to do it is just
look for the special point
on the trajectory.
So the special point on the
trajectory is this point.
By symmetry, it should
be corresponding
to sigma equal to 0.
So this point, it
should corresponding
to sigma equal to zero.
And so let me call
this point a z 0.
So this is essentially how
deep this string are going
into the [? back. ?] So
let's call that 2 [? bz ?] 0.
So it's clear at sigma
equal to zero, the z
prime should be equal to zero.
So this should be just
equal to 1 over z 0 squared.
Should be 1 over z 0 squared.
And then you can just
immediately rewrite
this as ordinary
differential equation.
So now you can immediately
integrate this equation.
And say z 0 is found, it's
determined at the boundary
condition by requiring
z L equal to 0.
So I will not do it here, but
you can do it in 30 seconds
to find the z 0.
You actually don't need
to actually integrate
this equation.
There's a simple trick to do it.
Anyway so let me just
write down the answer.
You can find the z 0 equal
to L. It's proportional to L,
under the square root of
pi divided by 2 comma 1/4,
and become 3/4.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
HONG LIU: Oh, this funny number.
AUDIENCE: 30 seconds.
HONG LIU: Yeah.
Yeah.
Mathematica will tell you.
Take you 25 seconds.
You type into the Mathematica,
and the four seconds
to check the error,
and the Mathematica one
second to give you the answer.
So you find this.
So we will comment on this
implication a little bit later.
So now we can plug
this into this action.
So let me see.
Yeah.
So now let me plug this equation
back into this equation.
[INAUDIBLE] [? star ?].
So there's again a
simple trick to do it.
You don't need to know
the expressive form of z,
because what you can do is
you can rewrite this V(L).
You can rewrite this
integral as follows-- V(L),
say this square root of
lambda divided by pi.
So this d sigma, you can write
it as dz divided by z prime.
So this is the d sigma.
You can change the
variable from sigma to z.
And then this just
integration become z 0 to z 0.
And then you have the 1 over z
square, 1 plus z prime square.
So now you can substitute
what is the z prime into here.
And now this just
become integral over z,
and just pure integral.
We still need to
minus [INAUDIBLE].
So if you plug into the
expression for the z prime,
and then do a
scaling-- say take z
equal to z 0 y--
because there you
see this all have the
nice scaling form.
So it's good to
scale the z 0 out.
So let's do a scaling,
z equal to z 0 y.
Then you could
rewrite that integral.
Sorry this is no V(Z).
This is V(L).
So you can rewrite that integral
as V(L) equal to square root
of pi, square root of lambda
divided by pi 1 over z 0.
So now I have to put
the epsilon in here
anticipating that this integral
will be divergent here.
So this is the same
epsilon we put in there
when we do the single quark.
So we put it there.
Yeah.
Maybe let me just
write one more step
so that you can see
it more explicitly.
Yeah, so I just plug this
in, plug this into here.
Then what you get square root
lambda z zero square epsilon.
Then I put a cutoff
in the epsilon.
And this becomes
[? tz ?] square.
And now I can do this scaling
to express in terms of y.
And then this becomes
square root lambda pi 1
over z 0 t y over 1
all over y square.
[? of ?] [? 4. ?] So
minus 1 over epsilon.
For simplicity, I will slightly
rewrite this 1 over epsilon
into the following
thing just as a contrast
as from infinite, epsilon
divided by z zero dy divided
by y squared.
You can easily do this integral.
This integral you
integrate as 1 over y.
And the other end it give you 0.
Lower end they give you
z 0 divided by epsilon.
And then z 0 cancels with z 0.
So you just get 1 over epsilon.
But the reason to
write in this form
is to see that this two
singularity indeed cancel.
So these have a singularity.
As y goes to 0, this
is non-integrable.
And here you have
the same singularity.
They cancel.
So when [? d ?] over [? y ?]
equal to 0, they cancel,
and the next order term come
from by expanding this term.
Then you get the y to the power
4 when you expand to this term.
[? In the upstair ?] you
get 1 over y power 4.
[? Other ?] than that, will
give you something finite.
So that just tells
you immediately
see that the singularity
have canceled.
So you will guaranteed
to get something finite.
You are guaranteed to
get something finite.
And another reason
to write in this form
is that this is
[? something ?] integrate to 1,
and this is something
integrate to infinity,
even though the
difference between them
is negative, because you have
agreed to do the calculation.
But this is because integrand
is not exactly the same.
But the fact that this
is going to infinite
give you a chance that
this become active.
And when you calculate
it, it indeed negative.
And the [INAUDIBLE],
literally you can do it.
Yeah.
So you can write
down the answer.
You find the answer is given
by something like this.
It's minus square root
lambda divided by pi,
then some numerical factor,
which is not very important,
but let me just write it down.
To the power of 4.
So this answer is nice.
So then now let me make
some final remarks.
So this is finite and negative.
So this pass the minimal
consistency check
that we are doing
something sensible.
We are doing something sensible.
If we find something
infinite, then that proposal
must be wrong.
You can immediately rule it out.
And if you find
something positive,
then you can also
immediately rule it out.
And so this is a
self-consistency check.
Oh, I forgot the
1 over y at z 0.
Oh, actually, if you
plug in the 1 over z 0,
I think you just--
no no, no, no.
I write it wrong.
This is not pi.
This is L. So I have
already plugged in z 0.
So z 0 is given by this.
It's proportionate to L.
And then this is 1 over L.
So this 1 over L is also
makes sense physically,
because 1 over L is just
the cooling potential.
And we do expect the
cooling potential,
because [INAUDIBLE]
as we said is a scale
[? invariant ?] theory.
And in four-dimensional
scale, [? invariant ?] series,
potential just [INAUDIBLE] the
[? ground ?] it will be 1 over
L, just by scaling symmetry.
It just exactly
[INAUDIBLE] [? why ?]
[? electromagnetism ?]
is 1 over L.
And so this just from
the scale invariance.
There's no other scale.
So the dependence on
L must be 1 over L,
because we have dimension mass.
So they cannot have
other L dependence.
So the second point is now we
again see this proportional
to square root lambda.
Again, this is a strong
coupling with that.
Because at weak
coupling, we know
it must be [? proportional ?]
to lambda divided by L.
And lambda is just the analog
of the fine structure constant.
And then this is the
cooling potential.
So 1 over L is always
true, no matter
the value of the coupling.
So you see, when you [INAUDIBLE]
the coupling from lambda
equal to 0, then it should
be linear in lambda.
Then when lambda
goes to infinity,
then become the
square root in lambda.
So now the final remark.
[INAUDIBLE] we see that z 0 is
proportional to L. So now let's
look at the geometrical
meaning of this z 0.
So this z 0 is how far a string
extends into the [? back. ?]
So if you say L is
small, then z 0 is small.
Now if L is large, if I make L
large, then z 0 become bigger.
That means that the
string extends further
into the [? back. ?] And when
you take L goes to infinity,
and this go all
the way to the AdS.
And again this is the
refraction of IR/UV.
Refraction of IR/UV,
because L corresponding
to whether you measure
UV physics or IR
physics in the field series.
So L small is a short
distance. [INAUDIBLE]
is long-distance physics.
And you see when you probe
long-distance physics,
then you are probing much
deeper in the interior in AdS.
And if you're looking
at short distance,
then you're probing the region
very close to the boundary.
Any questions on this?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: So are there any
interesting experimental
implications of
these sorts of things
that we couldn't get otherwise?
Could we have known these
four facts basically
without doing this
calculation by doing
more standard techniques?
HONG LIU: You mean this thing?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
HONG LIU: No.
Yeah, so this is really
strong coupling prediction.
AUDIENCE: So what
would that correspond?
What sort of thing
could you measure
in nature that would sort of--?
HONG LIU: Yeah.
So then what you would
do in your p-set.
So in your p-set,
in the last problem,
you will calculate this thing
at the finite temperature,
which we will talk of finite
temperature in a few minutes.
You do it in the
finite temperature.
And then you can essentially
calculate this potential
at the finite temperature.
And as you will do
in the p-set, there's
a [? screening ?] length.
And the finite temperature is
no longer scale invariance.
Beyond a certain length, the
potential will go to zero.
And you can measure
the screening length.
And people on the
[? lattice, ?] [? QCD ?],
that precisely match with that.
So you can compare
AdS calculation
to the strongly coupled
[? QCD ?] calculation,
spend a huge amount of computing
time, large amount of money,
large amount of
manpower on the computer
to do that kind of Wilson loop
calculation on the computer.
And then you see the
answer is very similar.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: That's interesting.
[INAUDIBLE] the strong
coupling I guess
is proportional to
square root lambda.
But the square
root of lambda was
what you said from
the beginning,
because [INAUDIBLE]
of the alpha prime.
It does not involve
the calculation at all.
So this [INAUDIBLE] produce
a weak coupling result.
HONG LIU: Oh sure.
Sure.
Because we are calculating
a strong coupling.
the strong coupling.
Yeah.
So this whole set-up is
for the strong coupling.
AUDIENCE: So this [INAUDIBLE].
HONG LIU: No.
But weak coupling you can
do [INAUDIBLE] diagrams.
You don't need this.
But strong coupling,
we have no other way
to do this kind of
calculation, other than doing
massive computer simulation.
And for some things, you cannot
even do computer calculation.
Good.
Any other questions?
Yeah.
So this is a good question.
So this actually
a very good point.
So this tells you
on the gravity side,
essentially anything
involving these [? always ?]
[? pointing ?] to the
square root of lambda,
just related one of alpha prime.
Yeah.
It just come from
the kinematics.
Yeah, but [INAUDIBLE] the system
the very nontrivial prediction
of the strong coupling behavior.
Good.
We need to go to the
finite temperature.
Because I want you to be
able to do your p-set.
So now we have talked
about how to calculate
the various observables.
Now we can pause a little bit
to talk about other generations.
So the first generalization
is [INAUDIBLE],
let's do finite temperature,
do a [? langio ?] temperature.
So so far, we, can
see that so far we
discussed AdS 5 times [? AdS ?]
5 string series AdS [INAUDIBLE]
is 5 string.
In AdS 5 times [? s ?] 5 is
related to [INAUDIBLE] series.
So we talked about this in
terms of small perturbations.
The normalizable mode on this
side should map to some state.
Say you have some
normalizable mode,
should do [INAUDIBLE]
some states.
And for example, the pure AdS 5.
So there's nothing excited.
This is example of
this [INAUDIBLE] kind
of normalizable mode.
So this is should be
due to the vacuum,
because nothing excited
on the field series side.
So this must be
due to the vacuum.
So now start with
this pure AdS 5.
Now as you start putting things
inside, excited the system,
then you will say in some sense
excite some normalizable modes.
Then you go to excited states
in your [INAUDIBLE] series.
And then one of the
obvious excited states
is the finite
temperature states.
So the obvious question is
what does the thermal state
correspond to?
Yeah.
corresponding to just save time.
So the gravity description
should have satisfied
the following conditions.
To satisfy the
following features.
So now we want to
guess what should be
the thing on the gravity side.
First he said it should
be asymptotic AdS 5.
That means that there should
be only normalizable modes.
There should be only
normalizable mode,
because the finite temperature
state is a specific state
of the field series.
So there should be no
non-normalizable modes excited.
And of course if the
field series have
a finite temperature,
the other side
must also have a
finite temperature.
So it must have a
So now I use T means
the temperature.
Now the capital T
means the temperature.
And in particular,
this should satisfy
all laws of thermodynamics.
And the third one
is that you should
have of course all
of the symmetries
of the finite
temperature system.
So you should have translation
variance, rotational symmetry,
et cetera.
Of course, a Lorentz symmetry,
Lorentz boost would be broken.
So you still should have
translation symmetry
and the rotational symmetries.
But the boost will be
broken, because now when
you add finite temperature,
you no longer have the Lorentz
boost.
So you need to find some
kind of gravity solution
which will satisfy
those criteria.
So there are two
obvious candidates.
So there are two candidates.
So the first is just
you can see there's
some kind of thermal gas in AdS.
So just imagine I have
some thermal gas in AdS.
And the second possibility is
that you have a black hole.
Because we also know a black
hole is a thermal object.
We also know black hole
is a thermal object.
So it turns out so
we will only consider
the [INAUDIBLE]
[? patch. ?] So we only
consider the boundaries is
really the r [INAUDIBLE]
rather than the [INAUDIBLE].
So the thermal gas.
So let me first describe the
thermal gas, a description.
So normally in the
field series, how do you
describe a thermal system?
So how would you describe
a thermal system?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
HONG LIU: In field series.
HONG LIU: Yeah.
A partition function is one
observable of a thermal system.
Say if you want to describe the
thermal system in field series,
what do you do?
Say if you want to calculate
correlation function,
you want to calculate
many other things?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
Euclidean [INAUDIBLE]?
HONG LIU: Exactly.
So normally in the field
series, what you do
is that you go to Euclidean
signature, and then
periodically identify time.
And the period of time is
the inverse temperature.
So we can do it here.
The thermal gassing idea is
essentially is what we do.
You say we go to the
Euclidean signature.
Yeah, let me call it t E.
We go to Euclidean time.
And then we identify
Euclidean time periodically
with inverse temperature,
which we always call beta.
And so in particular, the
fermions is anti-periodic.
Anti-periodic.
That means anti-periodic.
Of course, the
Boson is periodic.
But actually, this metric is
bad for the following reason.
So in gravity as a
general rule, whenever
you see a compact
space go to 0 sites,
then there's a danger of
having a curvature singularity.
It's almost always you have
a curvature singularity.
Only for some special
situations it does not have it.
And so this is bad,
because now when
you compactify this
Euclidean time,
this become a compact direction.
This is a circle.
And when you go to
z goes to infinity,
this circle goes to zero sides.
You can check that
actually this have
more curvature singularity.
So this is actually bad.
So when t is
uncompact, then this
is a coordinate singularity.
But when t become
compact, and then this
become a [? general ?]
singularity.
This become [? general ?]
So first this metric's bad,
because I have singularity.
At z equal to infinity.
At deep in the interior of AdS.
There's also a second reason,
which is more stringent reason,
which you don't need to care.
Let me just write it
down for completeness.
So if you actually
analyze a string theory
in such kind of space time.
So also there's a generic
rule in string theory
is that if you have a
very small circle, then
the string can wind
around the circle.
The string can wind
And then when that circle
become very, very small,
then it takes less and
less energy for string
to wind around that circle.
And then normally, so if
you have supersymmetry,
and also you have a
string wind around circle,
there's a [? casmir energy. ?]
And the [? casmir ?] energy is
typically is inactive
for the Boson,
and the fermion is positive.
And if you have a supersymmetry,
then that [? casmir ?] energy
cancels.
And then when the circle
shrink to zero size,
then the string become massless.
So that's typical
in the superstring.
But if you in the situation
where you just saw a symmetry's
broken, then
typically then there's
an active
[? casmir image. ?] And then
when the circle side
becomes smaller and smaller,
and then it take lower and
lower energy for string
to wrap around circle.
And then anyway,
if you include the
[? casmir image, et cetera, ?]
then you find the string
actually become
[? negative image. ?]
And you find that the
strings winding around t E
actually develops
negative mass square.
So as we discussed before,
this is called [INAUDIBLE],
and signals instability.
And here there's a circle
which become a small size.
And here there's no
supersymmetry, because when
you have a finite temperature,
your supersymmetry is broken,
because both on fermion have
different boundary conditions.
Anyway, so that means that this
option is gone, cannot work.
So the only thing we know
is to do a black hole.
So now we need to find a black
hole with the right symmetry.
So the reason I emphasized
with the right symmetry is
because when we say
black hole, it's
because a black hole is
a hole, is a [INAUDIBLE]
symmetric hole.
But here we need to have
a translation symmetry,
because this is a [INAUDIBLE].
So here now we need
to have a black brain,
black the whole horizon.
It's actually not a hole.
It's actually a plane.
So I did the black
hole in this topology
for the horizon topology.
Topology should be r to the d
minus 1, rather than a sphere.
Once you've realized that,
then it's easy to do.
Once you realize
that, it's easy to do.
So you can just write down the
answers, because this system
have lots of symmetries.
And you can just write
down the answers,
and then just plug into the
Einstein equation to solve it.
Say for example you can
write down the answers.
So you can write
down say r square.
So you can write down
answer's ds square equal
to r squared
divided by z square.
So now you still get
translation symmetry,
so you can put something
before dt square.
But you still have
rotation symmetry.
Yeah, so anyway, you can
write down answers like this.
Put in some two functions here.
So this is a most
general solution,
which is consistent with the
translation symmetry in the t
and x direction, and the
rotational symmetry in the t
and x directions.
And then you have
just two functions
which can only depend on z.
You cannot depend on t and x.
Otherwise you'll break
translation symmetry.
So these are the most
[? general ?] [? metric ?],
you have two
undetermined functions.
Then you plug into
Einstein equation.
Then you solve it.
So you find in fact h
actually equal to 1 over g
equal to something like this.
It's in d-dimension.
In d-dimension, say if
I have AdS d plus, 1
and then you find a very
simple [? metric ?] like this.
So let me again give
you a slight quiz.
So why I don't put
a function here?
So why in principle, I can also
put a function here, right?
So why I only put a function
here and the function here,
but not put the function here?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
[? Because it redefines ?]
[? z. ?]
HONG LIU: Yeah, exactly.
Because you can imagine this
just as a definition of z.
But then I don't have
freedom to choose this z.
Or I can choose here
to be 1, and then I
need to put the function there.
So in this metric, the horizon
we set z is equal to z 0.
z 0 is some constant.
So z 0 is some constant.
Zero some constant.
Right.
Is z 0.
And indeed I have a
topology of the R t minus 1,
because [? the d, ?] z equal to
0, the topology is at this r.
It's not at the sphere.
And also you see that when you
go to infinity, the f and the g
approach 1 with a very fast
fall-off with d to the power d.
So this is the normalizable.
And this is normalizable.
So this behavior
is normalizable.
So this is metric satisfy
all our criterions.
And under the standard
black hole thermodynamics,
we are sure this is a
thermodynamical system.
So this must be [? due ?] to our
finite temperature [INAUDIBLE]
series.
So now let's work out the
temperature in terms of z 0.
So it's just using
the standard trick
going to the Euclidean signature
which we have discussed before.
And the required the metric
is regular at the horizon.
When you go to
Euclidean signature
require the metric is
regular at the horizon.
And then you can
deduce that this should
have some specific periodicity.
Anyway, I hope you
still remember that.
So you can deduce a
temperature of the black hole.
So beta is equal to 4
pi to the d times z 0.
So you can deduce.
So this you remember, right?
OK.
Good.
So emphasize this is the
temperature matched in t.
Because whenever, as we
emphasized many times before,
but whenever you talk
about temperature,
you have to refer to
a time, time units
to define the temperature.
And this temperature is defined
with respect to this time.
So in other words, this
is boundary temperature.
So in the [? back ?], of course,
depending on the value of z,
the local temperature
is different.
And this is the temperature
corresponding to the boundary.
So this relation is
again very interesting.
So this is z equal
to 0 boundary.
And now on the gravity side
now there's a horizon at
z equal to 0, z equal to z 0.
And this horizon
according to this formula
is proportional to 1 over t.
It's proportional to 1 over t.
Again, this is the refraction
of the IR/UV connection.
Because if you can see
the very high temperature,
it means you are probing
very high energy process.
Then the z 0 becomes small.
Then the horizon
moves to the boundary.
And the horizon moves
to the boundary.
And when t becomes small,
then z 0 becomes big,
then the horizon move down.
So that means that
depending on the value of t,
you can probe different
regions in the gravity side.
So for very high
temperature, you
probe very tiny region
near the infinity.
And for a small t, you can
probe one or more regions.
Again this is a
refraction of IR/UV.
Any questions on this?
Now with this black
hole solution,
we can work out
[INAUDIBLE] thermodynamics.
And then we should be able to
work essentially by definition.
Then, for example,
the black hole entropy
should be identified with
the field series entropy,
or black hole free
energy should be
identified with the free field
series for energy, et cetera.
It just essentially,
if there's a relation,
if black hole describe the field
series at finite temperature,
then you should
be able to equate
the thermodynamic quantities.
And in this way, we can
actually use the black hole
thermodynamics now to calculate
the thermodynamical behavior
of a strongly coupled
[INAUDIBLE] series.
So we can now obtain
thermodynamical behavior,
thermodynamical quantities
at strong coupling
in the [INAUDIBLE]
series in a black hole.
So now let's do that.
So now let's specify
to d equal to 4.
So that's corresponding to the
four-dimensional boundaries,
and that's [? 2t ?] equal to 4.
So now let's first do
the black hole entropy,
which is the
easiest thing to do.
So the black hole entropy,
just the area of the horizon
divided by Newton constant.
So we have to use the factor
of five-dimensional Newton
constants.
So we work with AdS 5.
So we dimension
reduction on the S 5.
So we work with the
five-dimension Newton constant.
And then the area here
is just infinite volume.
It is just dx 1, dx 2, dx 3,
because this is just parallel
to the boundary.
It doesn't matter.
So what this defines,
or [INAUDIBLE]
times R cubed to the
z 0 cubed, because you
have to multiply the
area at the horizon.
So you essentially compute the
determinant of the spatial part
at the horizon, you
evaluate it at the z 0.
You evaluate it at z 0.
So you have this factor.
And then you have
this infinite factor.
But this infinite factor,
it doesn't matter.
We can just take it out.
Then what you get is
the entropy density.
So then we find the entropy
density is essentially
just given by this R
cubed divided by z 0
to the cube 4G 5.
So now you can just
plug in the numbers.
So now you have to
use this equation.
G 5 divided by R
cubed is related
to the [INAUDIBLE] related
to pi divided by 2 N square.
And then you plug in this
relation to relate z 0 to t.
And then, after a
tiny bit of algebra,
so you find N squared T cubed.
Again this answer makes sense.
Again, you can do some very
minimal consistency check.
So first thing you
said is that this
is proportional to T cubed.
It makes sense,
because we are working
with a four-dimensional
scale invariant series.
And entropy by itself
does not have a dimension.
And entropy density should
have dimension cubed
because of the volume.
You divide it by the volume.
Should be 1 over volume.
Do you follow?
So entropy density
should have dimension.
Entropy density should
have dimension M d minus 1.
Because at the d minus 1 come
from because you divide it
by entropy by the volume,
and the volume have,
yeah, 1 over volume have
dimension M d minus 1.
But here in the
scale environment
you don't have any
of the scale factor.
You only have T. So it must
come from T to the d minus 1.
So you get T cubed.
And also, this is a
proponent to N square.
And of course in the
[INAUDIBLE] series
should be [INAUDIBLE]
to N square.
So now you can also obtain, say
for example, the energy density
and the pressure, et cetera,
by calculating the T m
[INAUDIBLE] mu.
So you can calculate say
one [? point ?] function
of the stress
tensor Then you can
read what is the energy
density, and what
is the pressure, et cetera.
And so this is the
same as what we did.
It's very similar procedure
as what we did before
for the scalar field series.
The one point function
of the stress tensor,
you can read it
from the counterpart
of the [? B ?] modes, a
counterpart of the [INAUDIBLE]
modes.
So here the [INAUDIBLE] mode
is just this z to the power d.
And the [? corruption ?]
is 1 over 0, 1 over z 0
to the power d.
And so that tells you you should
be proportional to 1 over z
to the 0 to the 4.
Because that's an
analog of this [? B ?]
mode-- the normalizable mode--
to the 1 over z to the 0 4.
And again, this will
be proportional to T
to the power of 4.
Again, this is consistent
on dimensional ground,
because energy density have
dimension m to the power d.
And so it's T to the power 4.
But you actually work out the
prefactor request [INAUDIBLE]
effort.
Yeah, in a scalar case, we
say it's 2 [? mu ?] times b.
So in the gravity case,
in the [? metric ?] case,
it gets a little bit
more complicated.
Anyway, but you
can read the scale.
I will not calculate the
prefactor using this method.
So to calculate the
prefactor, it's easier
just to use the thermodynamics.
So because S just equal to
the free energy divided by T.
So now everything
here, we can see
that the density is
S is entropy density,
and F is the free energy
density [? exciter. ?]
So we know now the entropy.
You can just integrate
the free energy density.
So this is equal to pi square
divided by 8 N squared T
to the 4.
And then you can find out the
energy density of plus TS.
So you find this 3
pi square [INAUDIBLE]
squared [INAUDIBLE].
Now if you work hard,
the one point function
of the stress tensor carefully
of the [? free ?] factor, you
will find this.
So this is, as a result, at
lambda equal to infinity.
So these are the
strong coupling we got.
All these are the
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
HONG LIU: The
thermodynamical behavior?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
How do you get N?
HONG LIU: No.
You just integrate
this equation.
Yeah.
Just integrate that equation.
So this is the behavior,
that infinite lambda.
So now let's compare
with the free series.
So this is the undergraduate
thermodynamics.
So let's just calculate
the entropy density
with zero coupling.
So I have to remind
you one thing.
It said in each massless
[INAUDIBLE] degree of freedom
contribute to the entropy
density 2 pi square divided
by 45 to the power T cube.
I don't know whether you
still remember this thing.
So in four dimension, a single
massless degree of freedom
contribute to the
entropy density.
Yeah, this come from-- doing
a single massless [INAUDIBLE]
degree of freedom contributed
entropy like this.
This is a good
thing to remember.
And now in the
[INAUDIBLE] series
we have eight Boson,
as we said before.
We have eight massless
Boson degrees of freedom.
And then we have eight fermionic
massless degrees of freedom.
And each fermionic degrees of
freedom contribute to how much
of the Boson?
Do anybody know?
A massless fermion compared
to the massless Boson.
What is the ratio for
each degrees of freedom
contributed to the entropy
density in the free series,
free particle?
AUDIENCE: One half?
HONG LIU: No [INAUDIBLE]
AUDIENCE: One.
HONG LIU: No.
7/8.
And now in the SU(N)
[? Gate ?] series,
we have N squared minus 1.
We have N squared minus 1 in
the join [? representation. ?]
So now you can calculate this
is a [INAUDIBLE] free series.
So let's take [INAUDIBLE],
forget about the 1.
So then you get 2
pi over 3, 2/3 pi
squared N squared T
to the power cubed.
So now you find
something remarkable.
You find S lambda
equal to infinity
divided by S lambda equal to 0
is equal to 1/2 divided by 2/3.
So it becomes 3/4.
So you go from zero coupling
just to infinite coupling,
and the entropy change by 3/4.
So there's a long story.
There are several
long story I can tell,
a good story I can
tell about this thing.
But now I run out of time.
But let me mention a couple
words on your p-set problem.
So in the p-set
problem, you want
to compute that this Wilson
loop, the same Wilson
loop, the L and the T at
the finite temperature.
So now instead of
the pure AdS, you
use this black hole geometry.
You use this black
hole geometry.
Use this black hole geometry.
So what you will find,
so physical expectation,
physically the V(L).
So you expect the
potential between the quark
and anti-quark will go
to 0 when L is large.
So physically for
this reason, so here
this is the same thing
happens even in the [? QED ?].
So this is just the
story of the screening.
Suppose you have
electrons, anti-electrons.
So of course they have
interaction between them.
But now if you have a
plasma between them,
you have many positive
and [INAUDIBLE]
charge of particles
[INAUDIBLE] running around.
And then they interacting
will be screened.
The interaction
will be screened,
because there will be
slightly more active particle
here, and slightly more
positive particle here.
Then they will be screened.
Similarly, if you have a
quark and an anti-quark which
[INAUDIBLE] object, and we input
them at the finite temperature,
in the finite temperature, you
can cite many other massless
[INAUDIBLE] degrees of freedom.
Then they running
around [INAUDIBLE]
quark and the anti-quark.
Then they will screen them.
So when they take the
distance sufficiently large,
then you will find the potential
between them goes to 0.
So on the gravity side,
what you will see--
so now you cannot do
everything analytically.
But you can derive the
qualitative behavior
analytically.
It said if the L is small-- so
suppose here is the horizon.
When the L is small,
then of course
we just connect a string.
We're close-by.
Nothing changes.
Nothing much changes from our
zero temperature calculation.
And this makes sense,
because at a short distance,
you probe the UV physics.
And the probe, the
UV physics, of course
you don't see the temperature.
So for L is much, much smaller
than 1 over temperature.
Then you don't see the
effect of the temperature,
and [INAUDIBLE] will be
just like small corrections
to the vacuum [? we got. ?]
But now when L
become of [? all ?]
the 1 over the
temperature, then you
find something
interesting happens.
Then the L, then
this [? worksheet ?]
will roughly go to the horizon.
Then what we will
find in the end
when the L become say
larger than some value say
of all the 1 over t, the
only solution you can find
is that this string just
two string heading down.
That's the only solution.
And then that means that the
quark, anti-quark no longer
interact with each other.
And then they are screened.
Then they are screened.
So a short distance is
the same as in the vacuum.
But when you go to
long distance, of all
the 1 over temperature, and
then eventually it would get
screened.
So this is another
cute calculus problem
which I'm sure you will enjoy.
Yeah.
That's all for today.